[Music]
who'd you rather Drake or Pete Davidson
uh it's hard to choose they're both
extremely attractive and and pleasant
and um and fun to be with
who's your current celeb Crush Brad Pitt
because I was looking at pictures of him
on Instagram and he looked so great
I think he's aging
all right Brad you're still young but
you know what you are getting older I'm
not drinking very much you're an open
book yeah Martha was giving us all the
tea but there was one question that had
her sip in her new 19 crimes Martha's
lighter Shard who's committed the
biggest party etiquette faux pas you've
encountered
who who and then what is it oh my god do
you want to sip or do you want to spill
oh my God
what we do know is that she and pal
Snoop Dogg have had some wild times
together what's Martha Stewart like when
she gets really high
Snoop admitted to uh partaking in some
cannabis at your home did you join him I
did not Snoop thought that I was hiding
my real home from him he and he saw this
big beautiful stone building and he
thought ah what's down there Martha and
I said that's my horse's house so he
went down there and had some grass with
the horses
meanwhile Martha is starting the new
year booked and busy we're working on a
lot of different projects I have a new
series of shows on Roku streaming
television and uh that's why I'm here in
Las Vegas
Sin City is the home to Martha's
Restaurant the Bedford which she opened
last summer it's modeled after her New
York farmhouse
it is like going to my house for dinner
and that's what the menu is designed to
be food that you would be served at my
own home guess who's coming over for
lunch today Martha Stewart you recently
visited the Kardashians homes in La
which Kardashian
has the best home well I only really
spent the almost the entire day at
Chris's house and this is my closet oh
my gosh it's so great Chris showed me
every Square centimeter of her home
uh including her closets her pocketbook
closets handbags her refrigerators which
are extraordinary and uh her Library
they were filming all of this I I wasn't
even paying attention and then all of a
sudden it's on Hulu
[Music]